les arts de la rue ont leur première
journée nationale aujourd'hui
les troupes sont invitées elles étaient
invitées elles le sont toujours à
descendre dans la rue et à rencontrer le
public pour des happenings des
animations et le choeur de montreuil a
battu différemment cet après-midi s'est
insurgé tous les étals dans toutes les
choses nous voir exemple un treuil cet
après-midi la troupe locale investi une
rue piétonne et c'est le visage du
quartier qui se transforme les gens se
rencontrent se parlent sont contents et
ça apporte beaucoup plus de vie dans la
rue que les gens s'est montrée s'exposer
année des fautes et vous le théâtre de
rue un théâtre de rencontres qui permet
de toucher un nouveau public
on s'est rendu compte que dans les
salles finalement n'aller que toujours
les mêmes ceux qui considèrent que c'est
leur tambour qui ont des rendez-vous et
que qui ont certainement
et enfin nous ont ils envie de fusil
éd et c'est principalement dans la rue
que ce public même si l'apprentissage
pour le jeune public n'est pas toujours
facile peu peur qu'à la boutique mais
c'est propre à dubaï a lancé bien s'en
donner à montreuil et ailleurs
l'expérience devrait être renouvelée
l'année prochaine